the amount of people in the market that
claim to be something they are not
because what the reverse-engineering is
that's where the money is is the biggest
reason so many people lose you just
can't fake who you are you can't
manufacture it you can't want it so many
people here want to be business coaches
and they've never built a [ __ ]
business I'm worried about people that
are following the current trend instead
of following the only thing that they
actually are that's why it's working for
me because I haven't wavered regardless
of what you guys gave a [ __ ] about and
guess what entrepreneurship is not going
to be cool one day soon too and let me
promise you the quickest way to win and
I don't need money I mean win playing in
a way that feels right to you before it
feels right to anybody else around you
and I promise you that the majority of
you are not who do we cherish and who we
put on pedestal the people that from the
get punted everything else and when full
pledged themselves when you are all in
on your [ __ ] and we now live in a world
where the internet creates niche
communities around every [ __ ] thing
you could ever imagine
that is an unbelievable blessing to all
of us that our grandparents didn't have
an opportunity in mostly you'll pay some
[ __ ] money and you're going to
[ __ ] lose
I hope you think about what are you good
at or what's the truest essence of who
you are because those are the only two
things that create the upside that
people chase the people that hustle the
most are the happiest not the saddest
and the reason I push hustle so much is
because it feels like the most [ __ ]
controllable thing to change the outcome
of what disappoints you